ليس هناك جسر حالي في السودان غائب عن
ساحه المعركه او لا يلعب دورا محوريا فيها
فهي ممرات امداد تموينيه وايضا لدعم قوات
الطرفين بالعناصر والمعدات لكن ما اهم هذه
الجسور ومن يسيطر عليها البدايه من جسر
النيل الابيض هو يربط الخرطوم بامدرمان
السيطره عليه تعني السيطره على اكثر مراكز
الدوله حيويه وهو الان بيد الجيش فالجسر
يقود الى شارع النيل الذي بدوره يؤدي الى
القصر الجمهوري وايضا المقر الحكوميه مثل
مجلس الوزراء وزاره الداخليه والخارجيه
والمعادن والطاقه جسر اخر يربط الخرطوم
بامدرمان كما نشاهده وبقبضه الجيش يطل من
ناحيه ام درمان على مواقع عسكريه بينها
كليه القياده والاركان وقياده لواء
المدفعيه الراجمات اهميه السيطره عليه
تتمثل بالتحكم بمعظم حركه السير هذه
الحركه القادمه من جنوب الخرطوم عبر شارع
الغابه تقييد حركه المدنيين ميزه يتمتع
بها كذلك جسر المكنمر الذي يربط الخرطوم
ببحر ويمثل ايضا شريان خيالي المدينتين
وهو بيد قوات الدعم السريع الى شريان
المعركه الرئيسي هو المتمثل بجسر النيل
الازرق الذي يربط بين الخرطوم وبحري وهو
الان تحت سيطره الجيش يعد اخطر الجسور في
هذه المرحله لانه اقرب الطرق للقياده
العامه وتقع على طريقه اهم الوحدات
العسكريه والحكوميه بينها مقر قوه دعم
السريع وقصر الضيافه ورئاسه جهاز
المخابرات نذهب معكم الى جسر كوبر هذا
الجسر الذي تسيطر عليه القوات المسلحه هو
يربط بين الخرطوم وبحري ويشرف مباشره على
ناحيه الخرطوم على الاتجاه الشمال الشرقي
من مطار الخرطوم الدولي والقياده العامه
نذهب الان الى جسر الحلفايه هذا الجسر
الذي يربط اندرمان ببحري وهو يمثل قاعده
استراتيجيه منفصله
واهم جسر في المعركه الحاليه هو هدف
للقوات الدعم السريع وتحميه القوات
المسلحه بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
عيدنا بارود بس
الجسد
[موسيقى]
دي متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات